unknown to all four of you you've
actually been under two tests because
after I left I sent in a secret diner
and here's what they saw do you make the
bread here yeah oh the French mind every
morning comes down the clock usually
through the chef oh he makes pie smells
for the lecture I'll do like especially
the brown I really know he seems quite
proud of his father and what they do
because he talks about on a great
affection I kind of feel like I'm
sitting in the family kitchen it's made
it all a lot more personal actually
really good lovely start oh our horse is
this again watch Berger foie gras
terrine I think I ordered a mackerel
cultures excuse me oh that's okay I've
gone mad a second and busy how could you
confuse two tables
should remember what's going on damn
watching your food been put down on a
table in front of you is like eating
second-hand food whenever that happens
again food goes back into the kitchen
after that how'd you feel watching that
I could go and write those tickets for
you now and show you the correct
procedure and what ways could be so is
easy for you it would take me a favor do
that because I've been trying to do that
for about eight years but I get ignored
but he's you listen to you you so I
order fear the interesting thing is they
didn't ask me how I wanted the long dong
so I'm afraid when it arrives I made
this cover I've got a problem with it ah
thank you
I'm sorry paper I didn't realize that
the lamb came so pick what a big Gospels
have one better dung oh yeah I'm just
gonna see thank you surely you must ask
a customer medium pink well done no
that's their prerogative it's not this
old 1980s Shetland tally what I say goes
and it says the frustration doesn't it
it saves that dish being done twice oh
thank you so they bought two completely
new main courses other than bringing
back the half call first paper brought
by an entirely new main course that is
very impressive great recovery wonderful
covering the fact that you took time and
done two new main courses yeah
apparently ask the kitchen but you did
it without any hassle and left a really
nice impression despite the fact that
they actually ended up in full moon
courses they've only charged for one
each
so it's 40 panting it's clearly
experienced phenomenal food delicious
value-for-money
spot-on I want to come back here because
it felt like they'll come into your
house if you get up to speed with a
modern day system of taking tickets it
doesn't need to be that pressurized
putting those dishes down so we have to
look at the disorganization that's it
came straight back in the kitchen and
told Graham what done I remember now as
I've gutted that done it you know
because it said in eight years I've
never made that mistake before it would
be fantastic to sit there see that
secret footage and there'd be absolutely
not a single thing wrong see there hate
each other on the back and we'll leave
but life's not really like that